[Music]
okay all right give me anxiety and in
three two one go United States Canada
Mexico Panama Haiti Jamaica Peru
Republic Dominican Cuba Carribean
Greenland Salvador to protocol Colombia
Venezuela hundred again and still
Guatemala Bolivia Argentina and Ecuador
to the bozo Costa Rica Belize Nicaragua
but vidoes Bahamas Tobago San Juan
Paraguay Uruguay stuartandjulie Ana
Barbados and Guam Norway and Sweden
Iceland Finland Germany and I 1p
Switzerland Austria Czechoslovakia Italy
Turkey increase Poland Romania Scotland
Albania Ireland Russia Oman Bulgaria
Saudi Arabia Hungary Cyprus Iraq and
around Syria Lebanon Israel and Iran
with Yemen and evidence of smoke Belgium
and Portugal France again turmeric and
Spain India Pakistan Burma Afghanistan
Thailand Poland's as I can presumably to
the Bangladeshi to China Korea Japan
uncle allows to painting the news i
fella but I have survived you like it
you can East match in New Zealand a
Borneo and Vietnam chin s America you
can like bullets impact Peter PDFs wanna
boost apiece I'm busy line Gambia Guinea
Algeria Ghana but under the show to
Malawi chocolate Spanish Sahara has gone
19 ugh at my VD jubilant Gabon Tanzania
Somalia Kenya Mali Sierra no no dear
- home EMBA Senegal Libya Cameroon
converse here Ethiopia guinea-bissau
Madagascar Rwanda before in c'mon Hong
Kong I'm Debbie Qatar Yugoslavia crete
mauritania there just a media monocle HS
a molten palestine fiji australia sudan
[Laughter]
this time I'm speechless wow that was
what I feel thank you
[Music]